one of the interesting things that's
that's happening right now is that we
are getting this crosssection of people
who are calling out the BS more and more
and they're doing it in a way often
using provocative language because they
have been pushed into a corner and there
is nothing else to say other than this
little compilation we're about to show
you from Dana White Tucker Carlson and
Elon Musk and one of our big sponsors
called and said take that down you know
what I said oh yourself yeah
F you yeah don't ever call me and tell
me who to vote for and if your recourse
is you're a bad person for not believing
me you that's my respon f you black m
with money go yourself go
yourself is that
clear I hope it
is Dana White Tucker Carlson and Elon
mus don't have a ton in common
politically or culturally or probably
where they're from or any of that stuff
but why are these people being pushed
into a corner you know I was I was
watching that just now I was thinking
look over the last couple months it's
kind of become a running joke on this
show how often I've either said the f
bomb or tried not to say it or sometimes
I'm left with nothing else or like and
it's like that's what they're trying to
do with us they're trying to by through
censorship through lying
through all of the tricks that they have
they are pushing the rest of us into a
very bizarre place where we don't have
much other than a few
enough